what else is going on oh in the news i
saw this
um that uh
they had a gender reveal party and they
lit up the dang
forest in california
a couple people trying to beat open up
you know
a f uh you know somebody trying to beat
open a flaming armoire
with a golf club just so they can let
you know who they're so what the
gender their son is and california said
we ain't having any of it
and now there's a forest fire over seven
thousand acres
of male and female forest
have been burnt to the ground
that's that look man they don't you
gotta california's not
they don't nobody has a gender there's
no more gender there
they ain't doing gender
they ain't doing gender you try to
reveal anything's gender
fire that's the new rule there
oh you want to see this you want to see
it you know see if the baby gots a titty
or something they shooting open a damn
water balloon with a cannon dude a baby
got a titty or wiener or whatever bam
fire
the gender reveals they can't handle it
you know when i was young riley mal when
i was young you would look
you know you got to be five or six years
old you'd sneak off and look in your
pants and see what you were
i remember not i didn't know what i was
you know i remember one time
i'm over at my friend's house he's a
little bit kind of he was kind of fat a
little kind of chubby guy and he was
taking a break he was always doing that
you know we'd play any game we'd be 10
seconds into the game and he would turn
red enough to take a break
so i snuck off behind his house over
about a kind of about a firewood
looked in my pants and i was a man
there wasn't no party there wasn't no
cake after there wasn't no petty fours
you know no balloons no bs
but there wasn't any fire you know you
youngsters you want everybody you know
you know you got a wiener you want
everybody to have a damn
you know slice of homemade pie or
something
so just different man
it's just different what else have i
been seeing a lot of um
dude you know what i was thinking a lot
of these blm rallies it's all white
people
that's how lame they've gotten black
people aren't even
showing up to them anymore could you
imagine if a black guy showed up to a
blm rally he would be like this has
gotten
bad
this has gotten i i i just can't even
imagine
i'll say this um there's people fighting
in the parks and stuff and you keep
seeing it
this is what is it's our renaissance
fair
you know it the world has gotten a
little more
violent they got the ufc now
you can watch people beat each other
into unconsciousness
in three minute increments on the
weekend
brought to you by toyo tires
they're selling you tires while somebody
is losing
their ability to recognize their family
members
that's that's why a lot of protesting i
think you get these antifa you get these
proud boys you know you get these wild
cats out there
that's the new renaissance fair get a
turkey leg
go to the park and watch them
larp it out
that's all it is good evening good
afternoon and
other times thanks for watching that
video you just saw
i mean it was okay but the next video
you can watch could be way better
what if you watch a video right now that
changes your life well you could
watch this one or watch this one watch
this one watch this one
watch this one